raiders season doesn't start until this
fall but if you're looking for a fan
experience with some great food you are
in luck yes mercedes is at the end
resort at the new raiders tavern and
grill she said just eat baby right
that's right you want to get your eat on
you want to get your drink on here it is
the newest member of the raiders family
here at the m resort
and if you are a raider fan this is your
spot if you're a food fan
this is your spot everything las vegas
raiders
is in this place we've got very cool
open airy bars we've got
patio seating tvs everywhere and let's
talk about some of the food
and the drinks i'm joined by general
manager jose mourinho tell us about some
of the fantastic things you have on the
menu here
you know we're really excited about
opening the raiders tavern and grill and
one thing we really wanted to hit on
was the bar experience so we partnered
with modelo to build a bedello beer bar
and we partnered with remy martin to
build a ring martin alcohol bar so you
have an entire home
and away alcohol concept where you have
great very market cocktails
you have great modelo cocktails
including a lot of micheladas these
micheladas check these out this is the
original and this is the habanero
pineapple michelada
we'll be enjoying those in a minute
thank you jose yeah like he was saying
this is the modelo bar right here
and you can get all your specialty
cocktails of course your regular
cocktails that you would order too
back over there we have some other
seating that's the remy
martin bar that he was talking about and
for all of you that need to get your
raider swag
you can have a drink you can eat and you
can go shopping
we've got a raiders image right here in
the store
so maybe you want to get yourself a
t-shirt
a jersey let's see if we can sneak in
there how do we get in here
all right this is a brand new opening
tomorrow morning at 11 a.m here
at the m resort and we've got all the
raider swag you could possibly want so
what's better than some good eats
some raiders fun and i gotta get this
one
do i go with the car or do i go with the
jacob's jersey
i think i'm gonna go with the jacob's
jersey that's good now we can go eat
i'm all set you guys definitely want to
check it out the grand opening the vip
tonight
rumor is there maybe a coach or two that
are going to be hearing some players
that's happening at four o'clock
we'll be back in the 4pm newscast with
all the information
that you need to know but i'm going to
take this mask off and i'm going to go
get my grub on here i'm going to send it
back to you guys
too fun that place is cute it's going to
be popping tonight yeah for sure all
right thank you so much mercedes we will
check in with you in the 4pm newscast
and
kendall's still eating his wings you're
ready
down